hey everybody i'm off the grid for
august but my team wanted to highlight
this clip from black lesbian press
secretary karine jean-pierre
do you consider donald trump to be a
political rival of president biden i'm
not going to speak to that from here
well you talk about trump all the time
so do you consider him to be
i don't talk about trump all the time
ultra mega you guys were criticizing his
handling of culver last week you've
mentioned his january 6th response a
couple days ago
so can you say based on all that i i
didn't say anything about mar-a-lago i'm
just asking you if you consider the
president i'm saying from here i'm not
going to comment on that does the
president still want to i think that he
would be very fortunate to run against
trump in 2024 like he has said before
again i'm not going to comment on just
i'm not i'm president in the next
election i'd be very fortunate if i had
that same man running against me does he
still all i can tell you peter is that
the president intends to run in 2024
is there a concern here that if you guys
don't say more then these republicans
who
are accusing this white house of
weaponizing the justice department
weaponizing the fbi
are
but that's going to become the public
sentiment if you guys don't say once and
for all we are not doing that
first first of all
we're just not going to comment on the
department of justice investigation
we're just we're just not going to
comment on is this white house
weaponizing the justice department
and the fbi against against political
opponents
the president has been very clear uh
from before he was elected very clear on
this hold on throughout his time in
office i heard the quote we will be
playing the quote tonight at six o'clock
is this administration weaponizing the
justice department and the fbi against
political opponents
peter the president believes in the rule
of law the president believes in the
independence of the department of
justice
no that is no it's a yes a no for you
i'm answering the question
you may not like it but i'm answering
the question and i'm no no i'm answering
the question and i'm telling you that we
are not going to comment
on
a criminal investigation the president
has been very clear
i laid out what his thoughts were back
on january 7th in 20 in 2021 about how
he saw the department of justice and i'm
just going to leave it there we are not
going to comment from here from this
white house
on a criminal investigation that is
currently happening